hello everyone I'm Shireen and I'm Dan
hi Dan thanks very much for talking with
me today about this amazing game that
I've previewed recently what game is
this
it's called dungeons 2 the sequel to
dungeon wow ok what is dungeons I'm
gonna assume that there is some kind of
a dungeon involved ok well from what
I've played so far in the preview build
this game comes across to me as a kind
of like a cross between Dungeon Keeper
and Warcraft 3 ok which is great for me
because I loved both those games and
you'll see in a minute exactly what I'm
talking about but like it takes a lot of
inspiration from both of them heavily
I'd say Warcraft 3 aesthetically
especially and Dungeon Keeper
some orcs they're doing an obvious thing
yeah like they're even called the Horde
and the Alliance oh wow
that kind of like explains so this is
the start of the campaign which I
previewed and you can see that it kind
of looks almost like your like standard
Warcraft 3 RT yeah this looks like a
Warcraft 3 Matt looks like Stormwind
right and the troops there and there's
like humans and basically in this game
like Dungeon Keeper 2 or Dungeon Keeper
you're playing the bad guy so this whole
screen that you're seeing it's very
reminiscent of it like the hand the
floating hand which is called the handle
so this is your dungeon now we're back
onto the surface so we're back under the
surface and you know I'm building on my
dungeon here and as you can see like you
select areas that you want your minions
to mine out and you basically spend your
time and resources managing this dungeon
and building up an army where are you
getting the resources from so they're
mining at the moment the gold that you
can see
oh yeah it's embedded in the walls and
there's actually two different types of
gold so the green one the green square
at the top is um kind of like one off
gold you mine it and it gives you a lot
at once but once you've mined it away
it's gone huh and the one that had like
a smiley face on it was like long-term
gold which you mind away slowly but it
gives you like like it continues to give
you small amounts of gold right yes a
smiley face does decrease the value of
gold and so here I've just picked up a
couple of orcs which is like like
something you're doing dungeon keeper
combat is basically you pick up your
minions and you throw them at
you just actually drop them on top of
them and they kill the enemies and like
they just slowly hit them in there's
numbers that you can see the damage that
did they're doing who are the enemies of
these adventurers coming to try and rage
a dungeon they can't be in this case it
was actually spiders that I've come
across I thought there would be a
fixture you would think that but no I
dug into their cave they tried to
retaliate but I was like nope I'm
killing you guys fast good well done
these orcs um it actually leveled off
you can see when after they killed
something you see like a little exp
thing come up now from what I've
encountered so far the levels haven't
really done much diff no like stat
bonuses or anything sure so I'm sure
they it'll mean something later on we're
back on the surface now though so are
you actually leaving your dungeon and
coming out to raid a village or
something like this this is a warcraft 3
part of the game which I thought was
really interesting so you can see to
minimaps one on the bottom right corner
one bottom left the one in the bottom
left is what we're looking at right now
and when you send your minions up to the
surface the game kind of changes like
you mouse over and I click and drag to
select all your units and right-click
them to direct them to walk to places
yeah and so you don't have your godly
pick up powers it's completely like
almost completely changed and it's kind
of switched from lik what I called the
dungeon keeper mode to like the Warcraft
3 mode which is really interesting
what are you going up to the surface to
get so in this case the mission was to
destroy the king or like fight the king
and I went up to the surface to like you
know suss out what was happening and
like destroy a couple of things and get
exp for my minions but um over here back
in the dungeon the campaign actually
changes things up a bit by giving you
like different meanings and introducing
to them to you to their abilities right
so you've got goblins and such as well
and one of that unit over there that are
moving around actually he's gone
invisible Ness stealth through that
dungeon I thought that'd be interesting
to you
so yeah like you there's a bit of micro
happening as well up in the surface
world when you're controlling your
minions you can actually have them use
specific abilities that you research in
your dungeon yep and and like you can
research more rooms and such as well and
when your minions die in the dungeon
like they die in real life you can pick
them up and drop them elsewhere
or a hospital let's have them revived so
it's nice when a minion dies they
actually don't really die they've just
sound like a very very benevolent
Dungeon Keeper so so much for the
ultimate evil yeah so yeah there's like
a lot of little stuff to research and a
lot of things to do and I think also a
nice little touch was the humor in this
game as well it's very self-aware and
they make a lot of jokes like yeah so
you think this is like a pretty good
follow-up to the original done in Cape a
series III would say so I mean like I
had a lot of fun playing and I really
enjoyed it and like you know the
developer Eclipse oh sorry the developer
realm Forge Studios clips as the
publisher I think they've done a really
good job with this awesome
yeah like good on them for for putting
this game together and although it's you
know they're not really directly in
charge of the Dungeon Keeper franchise I
think this is really nice Maj and
they're quite enjoyed it nice
you